[Music]  60 minutes the CBS 60 minutes show they  had to apologize because they dubbed  loud engine sounds over video in a  recent report about the silent Tesla  electric car this is real take a look so  what is the future like apparently it's  fast and smoke free the tesla model they  added that engine noise yeah yeah they  put it over that I don't know why but I  have to say I'm not surprised sixty  minutes seems to have been playing with  their audio for quite a while now take a  look  conceived as an online bookseller Amazon  has reinvented itself time and again  they so-called pick ambassador walks the  aisles plucking and getting right away  before placing them in bands those been  who knows talk to you  I  [Music]  make it more exciting  [Applause]